Our Sports Lead now, former
NFL player
Michael Moore,
whose life story
was, of course,
portrayed in the Oscar winning film
The Blind Side, is now
claiming that
the family that took him in
never actually adopted him
and instead, in his view,
tricked him into a conservatorship
keeping or out of his own finances.
CNN's bringing grass
has more on the Sutton accusations
and the questions surrounding them.
Okay.
Big smile to his family,
Michael, or blindsided,
he says, by his family
at the center
of the Hollywood blockbuster.
Steve is your family, Michael?
You have to protect them.
Tony, here is the quarterback.
You protect his blindside.
When you look at him, you think of me.
Yes.
In a lawsuit,
the former NFL player alleging
he was tricked by Sean and Leigh
Anne Tuohy
believing they were adopting the 18 year
old budding football star.
He became part of our lives
when in fact they became his conservator,
saying, quote,
I have total
control over Michael Moore's ability
to negotiate for or enter any contract
despite the fact he was over
18 years of age
and had no diagnosed physical
or psychological disabilities.
It's a lie
or says he discovered in February.
Never happened before.
What a room to yourself
or his
life story from
poverty to NFL stardom
with the support of the two,
he family became a bestselling book.
Well,
then an Oscar
winning film
reportedly netting more than $330 million
or says he's seen none of that money.
And now nearly 20 years
later is asking the two weeks
for a full accounting of his share.
The suit reads
where other parents
of Michael's
classmates saw Michael
simply as a nice kid in need.
Conservators Sean Tuohy and Leon.
We saw something else
a gullible young man
whose athletic talent
could be exploited for their own benefit.
Sean Tuohy
telling a local Tennessee newspaper,
We didn't make any money off the movie.
His son, SJ,
not named in the suit,
told Barstool Sports
he did make some money,
but it didn't make him rich.
I mean, like 60 or 70 grand of, of course
the last four or five years.
The suit also claims
or who just published a book
about overcoming obstacles
this month unknowingly
signed over the rights
to his name,
image and likeness in 2007
without payment
or has publicly stated
he doesn't like how he was portrayed
in the movie.
I think the biggest thing for me is,
you know, being portrayed
not being able to read or write.
When you go into a locker room,
your teammates
don't think
you can learn a playbook,
you know, that weighs heavy.
The two say they are devastated
by the claims in the filing.
Quote, It's
upsetting to think we would make
any money off any of our children
but we're going to love Michael at 37
just like we loved him at 16.
Now, why the shoot is happening now
and how Michael just realized
about this conservatorship
back in February
are two of the questions
we propose to his attorney,
but we haven't heard back
the two weeks,
though, Jake have given us
a very lengthy statement
through their attorney,
essentially saying that
or try to shake them down for money
before going public
with his story,
saying in a statement part
the idea that the twins
have ever sought to profit off Mr.
or is not only offensive
it is transparently ridiculous.
Now, the next step is
they're going to have to respond
to the suit in court.
And so we'll see how this plays out Jake.
All right. Bringing grass.
Thank you.
Joining us now to discuss, Lisa McCauley.
She's in a state and probate attorney.
So, Lisa, as you know,
a conservatorship is usually made
because a person
has been deemed incapacitated.
Someone who cannot handle his
or her own financial or personal affairs
or says he did not know
that he had been put in a conservatorship
instead of adopted
until February of this year.
Does that surprise you?
It does surprise me.
And I
actually went to the file,
according to the Tennessee court records.
He was present at a hearing
when the two weeks were appointed
and in fact, his parents gave consent
to them to become his conservator.
So I'd love to see a transcript of that.
But it is surprising
that he didn't know
what was going on
even at the tender age of 18.
Are there any other reasons
that the two E's could have sought out
a conservatorship
and broadly
speaking, looking at this case?
Do you think that the two E's have done
something wrong here
in terms of the conservatorship
We actually
occasionally will do this for children
called guardianship
because it allows the parents,
the guardians
or the conservators
to place people on insurance.
And Mr.
to himself
said, we needed to do this
in order to get Michael into school.
And even though
I haven't been able to research
whether that was a requirement,
it actually does make sense.
So there could have been very
innocent reasons
why they sought conservatorship at any
for an 18 year old
who was still in high school.
Do you think that the two weeks
have done anything wrong?
I mean,
there does seem to be some evidence
that members of the family
did receive money from the film,
which made more than $300 million.
I haven't seen any evidence
that any of that money went to or.
What do you make of it? All
right.
Well, actually,
according to the fire,
once the orders got this court order,
they never pursued
letters of guardianship
or conservatorship.
They never took the oath, at least
from what I can see,
which means that
they never actually had legal authority
to act on Mr. Orr's behalf.
And that would be consistent
with his own statement
that just
three years later
he was presented with a contract sign.
So they received an order,
but they didn't act on it.
So it'll be interesting to see
whether or not they actually did receive
any of his money.